One of Bowlby's students, Mary Ainsworth, decided to test his theory in a lab,
by creating situations of security and separation between infants and
caregivers. She called this the Strange Situation Test. Ainsworth would have
the caregiver and the baby come to the lab. The caregiver was often the mother.
And the baby was between six to 12 months old. She would let the two get
comfortable in the lab and just hang out. Then Ainsworth would have the
caregiver leave the room for a few minutes, then Ainsworth would observe how
the baby responds when his or her caregiver is gone. Ainsworth focused on two
things. First, how the baby reacted when the caregiver left. Second, is how the
baby reacted when the caregiver returned. Ainsworth had hundreds of babies and
caregivers go through this strain situation test. What she found was clear
evidence for three distinct kinds of attachment styles.